This lecture is about how to mine text
data with social network as context.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue discussing contextual text
mining.
In particular, we're going to look at
the social network of authors of text
as context.
So first some motivation for using
network context for analysis of text.
The context of a text article can form
a network.
For example, the authors of research
articles might form a collaboration
network.
Or authors of social media content
might also form social networks.
For example, in Twitter.
People might follow each other, or in
Facebook.
Some people might claim as friends of
others etc.
So such context connects the content.
Often the others.
Similarly, locations associated with
text can also be connected to form
geographical network, but in general
you can imagine the meta data of the
text data can form some kind of network
if they have some relations.
Now there is some benefit in jointly
analyzing text and its social network
context or network context in general.
And that's because we can use network
to impose some constraints on topics
text.
So for example, it's reasonable to
assume that authors connected in
collaboration network tend to write
about the similar topics.
So such heuristic can be used to guide
us in analyzing topics.
Text also can help characterize the
content associated with each subnetwork
and this is to say that
both kinds of data, the network and
text can help each other.
So for example, the difference in
opinions expressed in two subnetworks
let's say two social networks can be
revealed by doing this kind of joint
analysis.
So here we are going to briefly
introduce.
a model called Network supervised topic
model.
And, this in this slide we're going to
give some general ideas, and then in
the next slide will give some more
details.
But in general, in this part of the
course we don't have enough time to
cover these frontier topics in detail,
but we provide references that would
allow you to.
To read more about the topic.
To know the details.
But it should still be useful to know
the general ideas and to know what they
can do to know when you might be able
to use them.
So the general idea of network
supervised topic model modeling is
the following.
Let's start with.
Viewing the regular topic models like
PLSA or LDA as solving
optimization problem.
Of course, in this case the
optimization objective function is the
likelihood function.
So we often use maximum likelihood
estimator to obtain the parameters and
these parameters would give us useful
information that we want to
obtained from text data.
For example topics.
So we want to maximize the probability
of text data given the parameters
generated denoted by Lambda here.
Now the main idea of incorporating
network is to say that to think about
the constraints that can be imposed
based on the network.
In general, the idea is to use the
network to impose some constraints on
the model parameters Lambda here.
For example, the text at adjacent nodes
of the network can be assumed to cover
similar topics.
Indeed, in many cases they tend to
cover similar topics.
We so we may be able to smooth the
topic distributions on the graph on the
network so that adjacent nodes will
have very similar topic distributions,
so you.
They will share common distribution of
the topics or have just slight
variations of the topic distributions
or topic coverage.
So technically what we can do is simply
to add a network induced regularizers
to the likelihood objective function as
shown here.
So instead of just optimizing the
probability of text data given
parameters, Lambda.
We're going to optimize another
function F.
This function combines the likelyhood
with a regularizer function called r
here, and the regularizer is defined
the on the parameters Lambda and the
network and tells us basically what
kind of parameters are preferred from
network constraint perspective, so you
can easy to see this is in effect
implemented
the idea of imposing a prior on the
model parameters only that will not
necessarily having a probabilistic
model.
But the idea is the same.
We're going to combine the two in one
single objective function.
So the advantage of this idea is that
it's quite general here the topic model
can be any generative model for text.
Right, it doesn't have to be PLSA or
LDA or the current topic models.
And similarly, the network can be also
any network.
Any graph that connects these text
objects.
This regularizer can also be any
regularizer.
We can be flexible in capturing
different heuristics that we want to
capture.
And finally, the function F can also
vary, so there can be many different
with combined them.
So this general idea is actually quite
powerful.
Office general approach to combining
these different types of data in a
single optimization framework.
And this general idea clearly can be
applied for many problems, but here in
this paper referenced here.
A particular instantiation, called
NetPLSA was started in this case it's
just an extension of PLSA to incorporate
some simple constraints imposed by
network.
And the prior here is the neighbors on
the network must have similar topic
distribution.
They must cover similar topics in
similar ways, and that's basically what
it says in English.
So technically we just have a modified
object function here as defined on both
the text collection C and the network
graph G here.
And if you look at this formula and you
can actually recognize some part fairly
familiar, because are they should be
fairly familiar to you by now.
So can you recognize which part?
Is the likelihood for the text data
given by a topic model?
If you look at it that you will see
this part is precisely the PLSA log
likelihood that we want to maximize
when we estimate the parameters for PLSA
alone.
But the second equation shows some
additional constraints on the
parameters.
And in particular we see here.
It's to measure the difference between
the topic coverage at node U and the
V.
The two adjacent nodes on the network.
We want their distributions to be
similar, so they here we are computing
the square of their differences and we
want to minimize this difference.
And note that there is a negative sign
in front of this sum.
This whole Sum.
Here.
So this makes it possible to find the
parameters that are
that are both to maximize the PLSA log
likelihood.
That means the parameters will fit the
data well and also to respect this
constraint from the network.
And this is an active sign that I just
mentioned, because there's a negative
sign when we maximize this objective
function we will actually minimize this
second term here.
So if we look further in this picture,
will see there is also weight of edge
between u and v here and that's based on
our network.
If we have a weight that says these two
nodes are strong collaborators of
researchers, or these two are strong.
Connections between two people in a
social network and then they will have
a high weight then that means it will
be more important to make sure that
their topic coverages are similar and
that's basically what it says here.
And then finally use your parameter
Lambda.
Here.
This is a new parameter to control the
influence of network constraints.
We can see easily if Lambda is set to
zero, we just go back to the standard
PLSA.
But when the lambda is set to a larger
value, then we'll let the network
influence the estimate models more so
as you can see, the effect here is that
we can do basically PLSA but we're
going to also try to make the topic
coverages on the two nodes that are.
strongly connected to be similar and we
ensure their coverages are more
similar.
So here are some sample results from
that paper, and this slide shows the
regular results of using PLSA and the
data here is DBLP data.
bibliographic data about the research
articles.
And the experiments have to do with
using a four communities of
publications.
IR information retrieval.
That means DM, stand for data mining,
ML for machine learning and web.
There are four communities of articles
and we will.
Hoping to see that the topic mining
can help us uncover these four
communities, but from these sample
topics that you are seeing here that
are generated by PLSA and PLSA is unable
to generate the four communities that
correspond to our intuition and the
reason was because
they are all mixed together and there
are many words that are shared by these
communities, so it's not that easy to
use the four topics.
to separate them.
If we use more topics, perhaps will
have more coherent topics.
But what's interesting is that if we
use the NetPLSA where the network the
collaboration network in this case of
others is used to impose constraints.
And this, in this case we also use four
topics, but NetPLSA would give much
more meaningful topics.
So here we see that these topics
correspond well to the four
communities.
The first is the information retrieval
second is data mining.
Third is machine learning the fourth is
web.
So that separation was.
Mostly because of the influence of
network where we leverage the
collaboration network information.
Essentially the people that form
a collaboration network would then be
kind of assumed to write about similar
topics and that's why we can have more
coherent topics.
And if you just listen to text data
alone based on the Co occurrences you
won't get such a coherent topics,
even though a topic model PLSA or LDA
also.
should be able to pick up a Co
occurring words, so in general the
topics that they generate represent
words that Co occur with each other.
But still they cannot generate such
coherent results as NetPLSA is showing
that the network context is very useful
here.
A similar model could have been also
used to characterize the content
associated with each subnetwork of
collaborations.
So a more general view of text mining
in the context of network is to treat
text as living in the rich information
network environment.
That means we can connect all the
related data together as a big network
and text data out can be associated
with a lot of structures in the
network, for example text.
It can be associated with the nodes of
the network, and that's basically what
we just discussed in the NetPLSA
But text data can be associated with edges
as well, or paths or even sub networks
and such way to represent taxes are in
the big environment of all the context.
Information is very powerful because it
allows us to analyze all the data, all
the information together.
And so, in general analysis of text
there should be using the entire
network of information that's related
to the text data.
So here's one suggested reading and this is
the paper about the NetPLSA where
you can find more details about the
model and how to estimate such a model.